how did science fair under the Nazi
regime next on history John Cornwell
explores that question from his book
Hitler scientists science war and the
devil's pact this is a little over an
hour thank you and now we're going to
get on to our speaker for tonight
um I just want to thank again the San
Rafael library associates for
co-sponsoring the event tonight
along with the Pasadena Senior Center
for graciously letting us use their
space um
Romans was very excited to have the
opportunity to sponsor an event with
John Cornwell he is a best-selling
author of several books and his most
recent book Hitler's scientists is a
historical look at science in Germany
and it during the beginning of the 20th
century and the moral and ethical and
scientific dilemmas that some of the
great scientists were placed under
during Hitler's regime and we're very
pleased to be to have him with us
tonight please help me welcome John corn
well
well thank you very much for that
introduction and I want to start by
saying how grateful I am to the San
Rafael library associates and to Roman's
for allowing me to come here and to talk
to you
you know authors spend all of their time
staring at the wall of a small room or
of eDRAM and it's quite a lonely
endeavor and so it's wonderful when you
get to escape from that situation and
you start to travel and meet people like
yourselves
you know your readers and a lot of
authors complain I've been on the road
now for three weeks from New York
through countless destinations to this
one and I've enjoyed every minute of it
because I get to meet readers and it's
very exciting and I always benefit from
it okay this book is entitled Hitler's
scientists and I want to start just
briefly to mention a few things about
what it's not about oh dear we've lost
oh somebody already have we are you in
the wrong place er it's not there is a
genre of books about Hitler's weapons
which rejoice in rockets and jet planes
and all kinds of wizardry military
technology which people actually enjoy
along with Nazi insignia and other
rather unpleasant things anybody who is
reading my book for that reason will be
extremely disappointed I'd like to start
with Hitler himself there he is at a
motor exhibition in 1935 just to mention
that the really interesting thing about
Hitler was that he was extremely
ignorant of science his knowledge of
technology really didn't go much beyond
the technology of the First World War
and he never informed himself unlike
Rose of
and unlike Stalin and unlike Winston
Churchill who all had committees and
experts who inform them
Churchill despised experts and he tended
to get all his information from
underlings notably his photographer for
some reason and it was largely because
of this photographer that he got
completely the wrong idea about atomic
science his photographer had told him
he'd read it somewhere in a magazine
that once the nuclear chain reaction
starts which is you know the necessary
prelude to an atom bomb that chain
reaction might go on through the
atmosphere and blow up the whole world
and so Hitler said at least to Albert
Speer who was his munitions expert and
minister but he didn't want to go down
in history as the man who turned the
planet into a glowing star
well what science under Hitler was about
among many things is first of all this
this is a picture of a Jew having his
nose measured behind the Nazi endeavor
in science was a whole philosophy and
pseudoscience of eugenics and a racial
hygiene to put it in its simplest terms
it was the biology zation of science
it was of race it was making a science
of race which worked in a kind of
pyramid with of course the Teutonic at
the top at the apex and Jews and blacks
at the bottom and so it any study of hip
science under Hitler is inseparable from
that ghastly aspect another aspect which
I'm sure you're all familiar with where
the experiments in the death camps this
illustrates an unfortunate camp inmate
who's being experimented on with a view
to helping the Luftwaffe with their
survival strategies and they made all
kinds of experiments for example dipping
them into freezing water or submitting
them to tremendous pressures in order to
test them on obviously without their
consent so this is something else that
puts Nazi science into a realm war of
its own this picture here illustrates
the rocket factories in the tunnels of
the hearts mountains and this is where
many thousands of slave workers worked
and were worked to death and it is in
again inseparable from science under
Hitler this appalling aspect of of the
work which was supported by slave labor
now
there's something else which is in a
rather different kind of sphere
altogether this man is max planck a
deeply civilized man who won the nobel
award he was the father of quantum
physics and in 1933 when Hitler came to
power one of the first things he did was
to dismiss all the Jewish scientists
Muslim came to America and to Britain
now there is a view that those
scientists who were not engaged in
racial hygiene not engaged in the use of
slave labor not engaged in experiments
on in the death camps but were good
regular decent people nevertheless are
acquiesced in Hitler's overall plan and
design by accepting
in the first place from 1933 at the very
outset of the regime this attack on
fellow Jewish scientists the phenomenon
is known as fellow traveling what does
the fellow traveler do the fellow
traveler accepts benefits from the
regime from the dictator while at the
same time standing apparently aloof from
the politics and the ideology and I want
to stress this very particularly because
the reason that I call this book
hitless scientists and twinned it with
my last big history book which was
called Hitler's Pope was precisely
because these two books are about the
phenomenon of fellow traveling in the
case of Hitler's Pope I was studying the
behavior of church men who took benefits
from Hitler while seeming apparently
aloof ideologically from him now why
should one mention this phenomenon of
fellow traveling what what is important
about it what's important is that
historians today in the last 10 or 15
years have come to the conclusion that
the fellow traveler often did far more
damage and was far more dangerous than
many of the card-carrying Nazis whether
they were churchmen or judges or bishops
or indeed scientists or academics and
the reason that they were dangerous and
damaging was that they gave such
appalling scandal to a younger
generation the people who were looking
up to them
this man Max Planck was one of the great
heroes of science one of the most
respected figures in Germany and the
view was this that if a Max Planck can
accept Hitler can acquiesce in some of
his major decisions and acts then Hitler
can't be all that bad in other words the
fellow traveler demoralizes dissidents
demoralize his people who have
sitting on the fence and scandalizes an
entire younger generation now these two
people are the man is Otto Hahn a very
great and distinguished scientist he was
the one who discovered nuclear fission
and the woman is Lisa Meitner who worked
with him for many many years I mean from
about 1908 right up to 1938
now I twin those together and I mention
them because Lisa Meitner after the war
herself pointed out the the horrendous
nature of the fellow-traveller and I'm
going to read you just a brief portion
of the book to explain what she meant
and then I will leave this topic alone
after that one of the most eloquent
critics of the scientist as fellow
traveler in the Third Reich was Lisa
Meitner whose arguments are all the more
telling as she includes herself in her
vehement condemnation of those who work
for him under Hitler in June 1945 a
month in which the truth about the
concentration camps was published and
broadcast in Britain Meitner poured out
her heart in a letter to Otto Hahn her
old collaborator towards the end of this
long and powerful letter she wrote that
what she had heard of the uncontained
horrors in the concentration camps
exceeds everything that one had feared
after she had heard on the BBC a very
factual report from the British and
Americans on Belsen and Buchenwald
she and I quote took to howling out loud
and could not sleep the whole night
recalling her memory of seeing people
arriving from the camps in a pitiful
State she wrote that Verner Heisenberg
another fellow traveler and many
millions with him should be forced to
see these camps and the martyred people
portions of the rest of the letter
deserve quoting in all their poignant
detail as one of the most important
denunciations of Hitler's fellow
traveler scientist by a former member of
their circle and I quote you all worked
for Nazi Germany and you try to offer
only a passive resistance certainly to
buy off your conscience you helped here
and there a persecuted person but
millions of innocent human beings were
allowed to be murdered without any kind
of protest being uttered I must write
this to you because so much depends for
Germany and yourselves on your
recognizing what you allowed to happen I
and many others believe that a way for
you would be to publish an open
declaration that you are conscious that
through your passivity you have incurred
a joint responsibility for what happened
but many believe that it's too late for
that
they say that you first betrayed your
friends then your men and children in
that you let them stake their lives on a
criminal war and finally that you
betrayed Germany itself because when the
war was already quite hopeless you did
not once arm yourselves against the
senseless destruction of Germany okay
now in order to summon up the energy to
write a big book like this one often
it's important to have a deeply personal
involvement and I have personally such
an involvement because I was born in the
East End of London in May of 1940 which
meant that I was conceived in September
of 1939 just at the time when war was
declared and I'm here to tell you that
my very first memory in life we all of a
state we have a first memory was of
something rather like this the sirens
were the first thing I remembered the
air-raid sirens and my father carrying
me down through the house and out into
the
yard or the garden as we call it we talk
about English gardens we had a beautiful
English garden at the back of the house
and in the middle of that garden
my father had dug a deep hole in the
ground into which to put what was called
an Anderson shelter it was a piece of
corrugated iron and he went down into
that when the sirens went but just as
before I was about to be taken into that
I was a child in arms I was four years
of age my father held me up to see a
flying bomb which was coming right over
the houses actually below the roofs of
the houses and whizzing along they made
a hideous sound like a motorbike with a
broken exhaust and everybody knew I
didn't know this when I was a child but
apparently twelve seconds after the
engine cut you had the thing landed and
exploded so that's my first memory and
this was a result of a typical flying
bomb and that happened quite close to
where we lived in London you can see
it's a lovely London double-decker bus
which has sort of gone down into a hole
that's another memory of mine and yet
another memory is not seeing one of
these things because you never saw them
these were the v2 rockets which came
through the stratosphere at enormous
speeds they came in silently and they
carried a much larger payload of about a
ton of explosives and I remember again
when I was age four my mother bringing
me back from kindergarten school passing
by where one of these things had fallen
and seeing up in a tree a pram a
perambulator where a woman had been
walking her child along the pavement the
sidewalk as you call it here and had
been blown up with her child and there
was the pram up in the tree now
what the interesting thing is that
people of my generation in Britain grew
up thinking of Germany as despicable not
so much because of the concentration
camps because we learned about that
later but very much because of those
terrible air raids which we suffered and
the flying bombs and the rockets and I'm
talking here about women and children
you know not the fighting men who were
mostly overseas or on the high seas and
so it was difficult for people of my
generation not to grow up feeling a
great deal of animosity towards Germans
and that was increased as one grew a
little older and I was able to get into
conversation for example with my
grandfather in other words we made the
acquaintance of the previous generation
and could listen to my grandfather
talking about the First World War my
father my grandfather had on his mantle
shelf over the fire several brass shells
which he had brought back from the first
world war which used to polish every
single day of his life and we got into
conversations about Germany and he told
me that he saw an equivalence between
all the stacks of cheap manufactured
goods which used to flood into Britain
before the First World War
typewriters sewing machines lamps I mean
every kind of consumer durable and the
stacks of bodies behind the trenches in
the First World War
and it was from my grandfather that I
heard that hideous phrase there is that
the only good German is a dead German
now I mention all of this because it
illustrates just how difficult it is to
write history in an objective way very
very difficult if you grow up thinking
that everything about a particular
nation or population is thoroughly bad
there was a book published not so long
ago by a man called Daniel Goldhagen
called Hitler's winning executioner's
which virtually gave the impression that
all Germans have a nasty gene which
makes them want to go to war and to hate
Jews I don't subscribe to that and I'm
going to move on to now to the reason
why I definitely don't subscribe to it
because as one grew up in the 50s and
into the 60s and became a student and
started to look at the world in a sort
of wider sense one had to first of all
cope with this problem which came out of
American Britain
namely the atom bomb and we can discuss
if you like later whether it was right
or wrong to make such a bomb as a
deterrent another matter of course you
know to actually drop it and people of
my generation as young students became
extremely interested in the fate of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki and all those
people who were completely wiped out so
what one began to as it were in a sense
measure up the score I'm not going to
say for one moment that there is an
exact equivalence between what we did
under the democracies and what Hitler
did with racial hygiene with experiments
in the death camps and with slave labor
we never did that another feature of my
growing up in the 50s was a much clearer
view much more detailed view of what we
did in our bombing raids against cities
like Dresden and Berlin and here's a
statistic for you in throughout the
entire war some 43,000 civilians were
killed in Britain in Germany 45,000 were
killed in bombing raids on one night
alone in Dresden
annuals and I mean some more figures
400,000 were killed that's the current
estimate and 600,000 wounded in Allied
bombing raids well going back for a
moment to those flying bombs and those
rockets it took some years for me to get
interested in the question as to whether
one of those bonds might not flying
bombs or rockets might not have had a
nuclear warhead was it not the case that
Germany had a nuclear program an atomic
bomb program why was it in view of the
fact that Germany was preeminent in
science through much of the early part
of the century why was it that despite
the fact that it was a German scientist
who was the first to discover fission
that they were not the first to get to a
bomb and of course for them it would
have been an amazing conjunction because
they were several generations ahead of
the rest of the world in rocketry and in
missiles this picture is it's in the
bottom of a cave at a place called hog
heigl Ock in southern Germany and that
is the full extent of the German atomic
bomb program as found in early 1945
that's how far they'd got they hadn't
even got a reactor going and this leads
us to one of the great conundrums of the
history of German science which is the
question of why they did not make a bomb
an atomic bomb
this is Verna Heisenberg arguably the
greatest theoretical physicists of the
20th century the founder of quantum
mechanics he was in charge of the atomic
bomb program
and his life contains an amazing
conundrum and it goes like this
two questions first was it the case that
Heisenberg knew how to make an atom bomb
but deliberately hindered the progress
of the research in order to deprive
Hitler of that first weapon of mass
destruction if that were the case surely
he would be the greatest here over the
20th century and certainly had he
succeeded I wouldn't be here to tell the
tale huh the second question is perhaps
on the other hand he did not know how to
make the bomb and in 1945 he set out to
give the impression by grabbing moral
superiority that he had not earned to be
a hero which he was not my book has two
chapters in which this is fully
discussed we've had a prelude to this of
course in that wonderful play by Michael
Frayn called Copenhagen I don't know
whether any of you have seen it better
that plays out in a different context
namely in Denmark in Copenhagen the very
conundrum that I'd given you well as I
related in my book we are now in a
position to know the truth of this this
is not very clear but that's an English
country house just a few miles from
Cambridge now to this house in 1945 in
May of 1945 were brought ten of the
great German physicists and physical
chemists who had been rounded up in
Germany brought to England and placed
inside this house under arrest for six
months every room in the house had been
bugged even outside in the trees the
military had placed Mike
phones all their conversations which of
course were in German were taped and
then transcribed and translated and
those transcriptions have been kept a
secret for more than 50 years now we we
know that the conundrum I just posed you
can be resolved by studying those
transcripts we actually hear the
scientists sitting down and having a
discussion in which they deliberately
set out a version of the truth to tell
the world in Germany it's a Alice at a
version of the truth we hear them saying
this is what we are going to tell the
world that we knew how to make a bomb of
course we knew but we deliberately
deprived hid the bomb and we by telling
hitless certain things saying was
impossible we didn't have the resources
it was too dangerous and focusing much
more closely therefore on peaceful aims
now this in fact was an extraordinary
despicable thing to do because it
carried a very very nasty sting in the
tail both at the time in their
discussions and we hear them talking
about it and in the early books which
had been written as a result of this
less art or this version notably a very
a hugely best-selling book called
brighter than a thousand suns which some
of you may well have read which was
published in 1947 written by Robert
Young who's a swiss journalist because
in that book Jung actually says is it
not ironic that these people working on
the Hitler this terrible regime resisted
the temptation to the make the bomb
while all those Jewish scientists who
were thrown out went to America and made
the bomb that was draw
Tom Japan that is a terrible and a
wicked myth which was perpetrated for
many many years well to actually sign
and seal the this conclusion there is
another transcript available to us now
of a seminar which heisenberg conducted
before his colleagues in this house in
August of 1945 in which in response to
their request he told them how a bomb
could be made
he explains them how an atomic bomb
could be made and on studying very
carefully the transcript of that lecture
with the aid of distinguished physicists
like Jeremy Bernstein who worked in Los
Alamos in the 1950s we now know that
Heisenberg did not have a clue we now
know quite definitively that he did not
know how to make a bomb and any
pretensions that he could have made one
were completely false and empty now I
think that the reason that this kind of
history is very important and the reason
that Michael friends play Copenhagen had
such a huge following was that it wasn't
the this study is not simply about how
scientists behaved during the war it is
also about how scientists ought to
behave and therefore that creates a link
with the present day because it gives us
a handle on examining the attitudes and
the actions and the behavior and the
morals of science scientists from 1945
up to the present day have we been any
better how did we behave could we be
should we behave differently but you
know there's a there's a really serious
and a big problem
about asking questions about how
scientists ought to behave and not the
least of those problems is the fact that
in Germany and elsewhere throughout the
20th century there has been a very
profoundly held view that science is
fundamentally value free that it has
nothing to do with politics nothing to
do with ethics nothing to do with
religion and in a sense that of course
must be true because at the level of the
atoms and the molecules there's no there
are no politicians and no Archbishop's
and no Ephesus water boils at the same
temperature in Peking as it does in
London or in Berlin and then there is
another question and that involves for
example the work of a man like this this
is Fritz Harbor probably the greatest
chemist of the 20th century and I have
an entire chapter on him in my book
because I think he's so important Fritz
Harbor developed a process which is now
commonly known as the harbor Bosch
process which fixes nitrogen from the
air and exploits it and as a result of
this process you had two consequences
one was that it supplied plentiful and
cheap fertilizer this was tremendously
important in a world in which unless
some new form of fertilizer were found
the planet would run out of food very
quickly it was estimated in the first
decade of the century that the planet
could only be hospitable to two and a
half billion people the present count is
something like six and a half billion it
would not have been possible without
harbor's process now here's the thing is
the really interesting thing about
value-free science if you like the very
same process that gave us these huge
supplies of fertilizer
also enabled Germany to prosecute the
war in the trenches for four years and
that is because the exact same process
makes explosives and so there you are
a scientist can say look science can
create good things and bad things you
know nearly everything is of dual-use
it's not up to me the scientist to apply
and to make decisions about how it's
used that's done by other people by
governments and military they're
responsible not us well I'll leave you
to ponder that it is I'm going to come
back to it in a moment but I just want
to make a slight digression about for
its harbor because here he is again
during the First World War
and what he's doing he's leading a group
of they were called um special pioneers
in a poison gas attack it was also the
same man who devised methods of creating
her poison gas as a weapon and he was
the first to use it he also thought that
it could win the war now this is
harbor's wife the first chemistry PhD in
germany a wonderful woman a woman of
great heart and great wisdom who had
married for its harbor in the hope that
it would be a wonderful scientific union
and partnership on the first day that
Harbor led a gas attack
in the first world war he managed to
kill about five and a half thousand
troops in the opposing trenches in one
go within minutes the next day he
returned home and threw a party to
celebrate before going off to the
Russian front to do the same thing as he
was celebrating and carousing with his
various friends
his wife who was so appalled and
disgusted went and got his service
pistol went out into the garden and shot
herself she committed suicide I think
it's important to say that you know when
we're thinking about you know how wicked
the Germans are well I blame myself in
it my own generation has this prejudice
you know there are many many stories
which actually work against that okay
I'm going to end with a story which
illustrates to my mind an important
principle within scientific ethics and
the way scientists ought to behave I
feel it's best to do it as a story
rather than telling this in the abstract
I want to start with actually that's how
it should be that's at Einstein of
course Albert Einstein and the gentleman
sitting with him is called Leo Szilard
who in my view is one of the great true
scientific heroes of the 20th century
Leo C large had been kicked out of
Germany in 1933 and he came to the
United States and he from 1933 had a
great fear that an atom bomb could be
made because he had almost a vision in
London outside the British Museum one
morning of how a chain reaction might
work if you had the right kind of
material namely uranium now in 1938
December also harm as I mentioned
earlier discovered fission other words
you could split an atom Leo Szilard knew
that the next step before you had a
chain reaction which might make the hue
bang of the first weapon of mass
destruction you needed something called
you needed to discover to prove in
laboratory conditions something called
secondary neutrons now don't be
frightened of the technology of this
just take that on trust as if it is the
next stage before you can go to a chain
reaction and we'll leave it at that now
there were two groups of scientists
working on this quest for secondary
neutrons one wasn't an Italian Jew who
was working in Columbia University he'd
been kicked out of Italy because of
Mussolini's race laws and the other was
a man called Giulio curry here he is who
was working in Paris now Leo Szilard
approached these two scientists and said
I know what you're working on we all
know that this could be the prelude to a
chain reaction and therefore a weapon of
mass destruction
I implore you not to publish your
results if you reach that conclusion and
it's quite obvious why I was saying that
we this was in February of 1939
everybody knew there was going to be a
war everybody knew that Germany had many
fine scientists and therefore
discoveries had huge implications even
if we're talking in terms of months or
weeks or days you know in a race towards
a weapon of mass destruction
well surely Oh Curie was non-committal
in his reply and in March of 1939 he
discovered his secondary neutrons and he
published straight away in the
distinguished British magazine science
magazine called nature on the 18th of
March now it so happened that in Germany
at this time was
a man called Paul haar Tech our Paul
haar Tech was a German he was a physical
chemist he was very interested in
neutrons he'd worked under James
Chadwick in Cambridge in 1932 he spoke
perfect English and read perfect English
he read the article in nature published
on the 18th of March and he thought I've
got a good idea I need funding to do
more work on neutrons he wasn't
interested in bombs wasn't interested in
the Nazis he was interested in getting
some money so off he went to Army
Ordnance in Berlin the German weapons
division and he said I've got a good
idea who could you give me funding
because you know you might get something
out of this and the way of a huge bomb
and thus it was that the German atomic
bomb effort began after the war people
asked Paul haar tech what did you think
you were doing didn't didn't you realise
that you might be giving hit for the
bomb and he said oh I wasn't doing it
for that reason I just had not enough
funds going to do my research and I
thought that you know the army had
plenty of money say they would give it
to me
which is rather like you all know the
story of Willy Sutton don't you the man
who robbed banks and they said well
why'd you rob banks you said oh well of
course I robbed banks was that's where
the money is and now I mention this
story for two reasons the first is that
in terms of ethics there are times when
scientists should not publish just as
there are times when they should publish
and also it's important to point out
that be the problem of being a good
scientist and I don't mean just a clever
one but I mean good in the widest
possible sense has a lot to do with the
fact that scientists are unusually
dependent on their proprietors their
paymasters the people who give them
their funding and they're usually not
scientists they are the military their
governments
their National Health Organization's
pharmaceutical companies and so forth
and you know scientists to this day I
will more now than ever before more than
in the days of Paul haar tech spend an
enormous amount of their time writing
grant applications for money I in
Cambridge where I work surrounded by
scientists I'm more a historian of
science than actual scientists
scientists tell me that they spend up to
fifty percent of their time writing
grant applications and these things are
rather like movie scripts you know
because there is a great deal of fantasy
involved because they are telling the
proprietors of science what they want to
hear and into issuing promissory notes
not least of which is that the
proprietors of science will own the
intellectual property rights of what
they've made and patent what they've
discovered how much longer should would
you like me to talk for you had enough
five five five or ten moments okay
before we leave this question of funding
I can't resist mentioning this fella can
you see him his Verna von Braun he was
the great rocket engineer who at the end
of the war was brought over by the
Americans with 150 of his assistants
rocket engineers and he famously said at
the end of the war I don't care whether
I work for an Uncle Joe or an Uncle Sam
so long as I work for a rich uncle that
gives you a sense of the reality of
somebody who says that science is value
free science is a moral sciences
fundamentally apolitical that is what
you end up with but that kind of
despicable view
well I want to end by not sure whether
you're going to read this
just a few things to think about
it was Rabelais who came out with that
first statement their science without
conscience is the ruin of the soul is
this true I certainly think it is or is
fundamental science value-free a
political amoral I certainly don't
believe that that's the case and I argue
very very strongly against this in my
book
our scientists responsible for the uses
to which their discoveries are put by
others well if they know what the
consequences are and they're going to be
bad surely they should and surely to
them scientists should not put dangerous
knowledge into the hands of people they
don't trust is a democracy the best of
all possible environments for good
science and does the practice of good
science encourage and promote the ideals
of democracy well this brings us to the
record of science and let's stick with
the West Europe and Western Europe and
the United States since 1945 tragically
the moment the war was over although we
were all though democracy had won we
entered into the Cold War science became
big science it became dominated by the
military and industry it was taken over
by secrecy because of course we were in
antagonistic confrontation with the
Soviet Union and alas I believe that
scientists became more and more used to
the idea that hundred democracy you had
to trust your leaders that they would
always do the right thing and so science
as a whole many communities of science
began to abdicate their sense of
responsibility for their generation of
knowledge and for their discoveries
we've seen many extraordinary things for
which we deserve to be ashamed just to
itemize a few of them there was the
Tagus key syphilis experiment despite
the fact that it was American lawyers
who at the Nuremberg trials had put
together those protocols and principles
to do with experiment on human beings
only with their consent we saw in
Washington State in the 1960s the
contamination of 8,000 square miles of
territory with radioactive materials in
order that the military would be able to
get a handle on how to test for
plutonium sites in the Soviet Union and
so it goes on through the period in
which we develop tactical nuclear
weapons not as a deterrent but for
possible use that only ended with when
Kennedy came to power and so on through
to the present day when we have on the
one hand new research on weapons of mass
destruction mini nukes so-called which
blur the distinction between
conventional and nuclear weapons in the
area of biology scientists face without
getting into what I believe to be the
right and the wrong but nevertheless
it's a question of science scientists
having their ethics tested we have the
wholesale patenting of all kinds of
areas of nature including even you know
molecules and genes and we have research
too on human embryos in order to further
knowledge of stem cell work in other
words what I'm saying is that it is very
naive to believe that because we live
under a democracy that we can add
Kate as scientists we can abdicate to as
non-scientists our responsibilities
towards what scientists do and I'd like
to simply end by saying that the
difference between science 50 60 years
ago and science today is that we now
have the Internet and we have free and
pluralist media and scientists can
really act as whistleblowers and fight
back and publicize form into groups in
order to have debates and to alert a
wider public to the way in which science
conducts itself and to give you just one
example of that I don't know how many of
you saw the film The Outsider there was
the scientist Jeffrey Wigand who worked
the tobacco company who saw that his
company was experimenting with chemicals
that would make cigarettes even more
addictive and he blew the whistle on
them at great cost to himself his family
broke up he lost his health benefits and
so forth it may well be that it is
difficult for scientists and heroism is
called for but nevertheless I think it
can be done and we should all be part of
that because it's important that all of
us feel a sense of responsibility for
what scientists do and in order to do
that we have to keep abreast of science
and we have to keep up with what the
media is doing and what them
whistleblowers are telling us okay thank
you
if you have thank you very much if you
have a question would you step forward
to the microphone and address it
strictly through that that's very
important yeah Mr Carr well I was going
to ask you if you are aware of a series
of books put out in Europe number of
years ago called Hitler's doctors and
then ahem
I do know that you do not the books they
were if for a book in my book there is a
huge bibliography and I I hope in three
years there's not a book that I have
left on read which is to do with the
subject okay now that my second question
are you aware that in our great state of
California for many years mental
patients and their so-called
undesirables were sterilized and that
some of these ideas were adapted in
Germany at the time of the Nazis
yes I'm I am very well aware of that
I think that what and also I should say
that the same was happening in
Scandinavia and in Britain and what you
say is very important because these
ideas about eugenics and racial hygiene
will Kane not out of biology as such not
mainstream biology but actually out of
psychiatry and particularly in German
mental institutions after the First
World War
I think the difference where Germany
took off into a realm of its own was in
the definition of the life that is not
worth living once that had been defined
but interestingly that was first
conceived inside mental hospitals by a
liberal initiative and that initiative
was when occupational therapy
was introduced in the 1920s into German
psychiatric institutions they divided
those who they thought would benefit
from occupational therapy and those who
wouldn't and that's where you began to
see this notion of the life not worth
living which could be ended and it's
interesting too that the way in which
those lives not worth living were done
away with namely through gassing was the
prelude to the death camps that you know
there's an exact continuity between that
process I thank you for your questions
very good
comment more than a question you're
obviously very upset or concerned about
the atom bombing of Germany and the
firebombing that your government knows
did at Dresden in other cities and that
was horrible
but the Germans were determined to
conquer your country and we would have
been next and I think as an American and
as a Jew I am only sorry we are you
didn't have the atom bomb in 1941 or two
and could have dropped it on Berlin
which probably would have saved many
many millions of lives and so and I will
admit when I went to Germany and I saw a
little hillocks in Berlin where a lot of
innocent Germans were buried because of
our bombs I felt sorry for them but I
feel a lot sorry if Germany had
conquered us so I just like to make that
comment I also understand that the
carpet bombing may have prolonged the
resistance of the Germans which was
regrettable too
yep well thank you for that comment and
I respect every opinion of that kind I
would only this is not a repast or a
battle to what you've said so I respect
what you say aspect to opinion the I
mentioned that term carpet bombing in
the context of the way in which science
and technology adds to the death so it's
not a comment really about whether I
thought it was right or wrong
it was just what can be done through
science just as I made I might well have
mentioned the fact that Agent Orange was
used in Vietnam and the consequence of
that was that in that part of Southeast
Asia something like 30% of the food
production was destroyed for a whole
decade now that's not going into the
rights and wrongs of the war and the
prosecution of the war it is about what
science and technology can do really
it's a comparison between
hit the technology under Hitler and
technology in our hands okay not really
knowing how to make the atomic bomb and
I wondered if in in that respect and the
fact that they kind of relied on his
judgment that he might have helped
prevent Germany from actually producing
the hydrogen the atomic bomb yeah well
that's how I thank you sir as I was
saying the conundrum was one he knew how
to do it and prevented it that's what
you're saying that's what I said earlier
that's the first half of them this is
why it's a conundrum because you know
there are two halves to it the other was
he didn't know but pretended that he did
in order to grab morals periodic so I
gone that's true and it's that's fully
discussed in my book because the Manhart
egg the Willie Sutton of science that I
mentioned said after the war that it was
preposterous that Heisenberg should be
in charge of the atomic bomb program
because he was a theoretician
he'd never in his life done a big
experiment you know not lime done any
small ones either and it it is
interesting that I believe you me you
can make out a case for Heisenberg being
that hero
but I think on weighing the evidence
particular the most recent stuff the
tapes I think you come round to the view
that I take but I would go beyond that
and I think it's very important to say
that you know it could well be a little
bit like the wartime PO past the 12
could he have done more to save the Jews
you end up with debates about the
conscience of a human being
without sufficient evidence as to you
know what was really going on inside his
head but that leads us to the next stage
of the argument which is okay this is
how we think they behaved how all they
to have behaved you know in the best
possible circumstances which is what I
want to get to in other words I want to
get away from the view that science
sorry that ethics is simply not a
question for scientists at all that's
how the Germans thought you know all
scientists in Germany were civil
servants and so they were used to the
idea that you don't get involved in
politics also they'd had the example of
the great Max Weber the social scientist
who in the 1920s in order to avoid
social science being hijacked by
ideologies the right or the left
insisted that science should be separate
from any kind of ideology or politics
well I can you wait because this
gentleman hasn't had a chance at asking
a question okay impression that the
tapes were not available at the time we
play Copenhagen was written is that a
correct assumption or were those tapes
available at the time when the play was
written well actually they were
available because they'd been an early
edition a British Edition in 1993 which
I don't think Michael Frayn had read
Michael Frayn based his book on a book
on sorry his play on a book by Thomas
powers who very unpleasantly reviewed my
book in the Los Angeles Times in order
to defend his own wrong view of
Heisenberg as a hero and I think that
it's quite clear that because his whole
focus was on the Copenhagen incident
that's just as Thomas powers
super-small Heisenberg swore he rather
overlooked the significance of the tapes
and also the first edition of the tapes
was by a civil servant whereas the
second one published in 2000 was edited
by Jeremy Bernstein who is a very
eminent physicist as well as being a
great writer you know he writes The New
Yorker and the New York Review of Books
so he wasn't quite up to scratch on the
evidence thank you so very good later
wonderful play yeah
but of course he's been attacked for
being a moral relativist because he
doesn't really come to any conclusion he
draws this equivalence between
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle and
the view that perhaps all of history and
biography is equally uncertain so on
this note of moral relativism I wonder
if you could share with us your feelings
you you pointed out them the the fellow
traveling syndrome among the scientists
right was it stronger among the
scientists than any other group of
Germans well let's say that as a group
that the significant fellow-traveller
group were people at a high level within
their professions churchmen high
churchmen judges and lawyers academics I
mean people like Martin Heidegger great
philosopher and scientists because these
people were respected and looked up to
you know as kind of exemplars by a
younger generation and people who hadn't
quite made up their minds and so it's
really I don't think that scientists
anymore than any of the other groups but
there then there comes the consideration
and who was the most dangerous because
of course the scientists had it within
their power you know to make atom bombs
Rockets so it had consequences which
were rather different than from the
other professions I think that the case
of the church stands really on its own
the and really it's what my book
Hitler's Pope is about I don't think now
I mean it's four years on since I
published that book but we will ever
really know whether Pius the 12th was
culpable during the war because his
scope of action was so limited I mean he
was virtually a prisoner in the Vatican
and again we're back to trying to
interpret it what was going on his
conscience but in 1933 when he was
Secretary of State which is like the
foreign minister for the Vatican with
total freedom to negotiate with Hitler
he was the great German esteemed in
Germany for 16 years
that was another matter an extraordinary
matter because he negotiated a treaty
called the rights Concordat with Hitler
in April of 1933 onwards actual July and
the nub of that agreement was that the
Vatican would be able to exercise
greater power over German Catholics in
appointing bishops in running the
schools him be and indeed getting
greater funding for schools and more
school buildings at just the time when
Jewish pupils and students were being
deprived of places when their teachers
were being thrown out of their jobs and
the great benefit that Hitler got back
from this agreement was the withdrawal
of Catholics from social and political
action the demise of the great Catholic
center party which was the last
Democratic Party in Germany after and
only after they had voted for the
enabling act that made Hitler a dictator
and that to me is you know a really
quite catastrophic piece of fellow
traveling because never did a Eugenio
Pacelli the Pewter Pius the 12th during
that time
ever profess to liking Hitler he hated
him he loathed him he loathes and
answers but this was the signal to the
whole world was after all the Catholic
Church is a global organization a signal
to the world that you could do deals
with Hitler that dignified Hitler gave
him credibility yep
in your boat boat iceberg as his
rationale for refusing to swear
allegiance to Hitler and join the Nazi
Party that he merely wanted to shut out
the ugliness of the outside world sorry
who is this Heisenberg Heisenberg sorry
Oh idiot it says in your book that he
showed off the ugliness of the outside
world and concentrate on the beauty of
his own research
oddly enough the same philosophy of
political are of a scientific neutrality
was also prevalent among the Manhattan
Project scientists Oppenheim ER Niels
Bohr Fermi Klaus Fuchs slizzard who all
believe that whatever they discovered
should be shared with in this case all
the anti-fascist countries and
particularly the Soviet Union they had
little idea what Stalin's Russia was
like or that the atomic research program
there was none in the direction of the
secret police chief Lavrentiy Beria
but it does raise the question then do
scientists have an obligation to also
expand their research into their pure
beauty of their research and perhaps
look at some of the ugliness of the
world before they again try to share all
the secret to their research hey
excellent remarks thank you sir
absolutely excellent and to underline
your comment there I think it has to be
said that most of the scientists at Los
Alamos had squared their conscience in
making an atom bomb because they
genuinely believed that Hitler was
making one too and was ahead and this
was the only way to deal with it
by having a deterrent now isn't it
interesting that in 1944 December 1944
when
all those the all source teams of the
Americans and the British rushed into
Germany to just like you know they've
been doing in Iraq to see find out
weapons of mass destruction well there
with much greater than speedier success
I must say as soon as they discovered
they'd soon discovered in December that
there was no atomic bomb they were
nowhere near making one now did this not
wholly negate the point of what those
scientists were doing Los Alamos should
they have not all stopped in their
tracks and then said well we don't need
to make this damn thing there was only
one scientist who resigned at that
moment and his name is Joseph Rotblat he
was originally polish went to Britain
and then came to United States the
military general groves and his military
organization who were running the atom
bomb program at los alamos huddled him
rushed him out he was deprived of any
opportunity to speak to his colleagues
and he was forced to maintain silence
Joseph Rotblat is alive to this day is
94 years of age he founded the Pugwash
project which is anti-nuclear and writes
brilliantly to this day and promoting
his views and his chiefly famous for the
statement that a scientist is a human
being first and a scientist second which
i think is what you are saying yep
good thank you so much
John Cornwell is a regular contributor
to the Sunday Times of London and author
of several science books as latest as
Hitler's scientists science war and the
devil's pact it's published by Viking
online at penguin Putnam com next week
history on book TV features Patricia
beard on business ethics in the 1900s
and to find out about the authors